Okay, cool. Well, now it's official that we're being recorded, so don't say anything offensive.
You're late.
Cool. Well, I guess if you're cool with it, we can dive right in.
Yeah, dude. Let's do it.
Well, I think I'll start with a confession, is that I thought it'd be cool to have you on the podcast for quite a long time, but it always felt weird because I know you personally.
And then I was telling somebody about this recently, and they're like, yeah, dude, it's kind of dumb. You should get them on.
Well, you know, it's like, it's actually so far, we've been talking for like three minutes. It's the most enjoyable one I've done in the last decade, because I know you, and we're tight.
So it's very nice. You should have done it earlier. Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, I should have.
What's could be better now because we waited so long.
Yeah, totally. Totally.
What are you reading these days?
I am actually, I just, I kind of go back and forth between fiction and nonfiction.
I'm reading this, this novel right now called The Impossible Thing.
Just crazy story. I love, I really love, like Irish writers. They're just so freaking good.
This woman's well, so she's not cheating a little bit, but it's this like incredible, it's kind of like a crime thing, but the crime at the center of it is a rare egg that gets stolen.
So it's just sort of like really eccentric, and it has multiple timelines.
I don't know. It's just like one of those really fascinating things. I'm loving it.
What's the name of it?
The Impossible Thing.
I'll add it to my never ending list of books that I should read someday.
Yeah, do it.
I think I've asked you this before, but do you ever read any other EMS books?
You know, I don't. When I was in it, I didn't want to, like, you know, I went home and I was like, I don't want to like do this when I'm at home.
And then once I knew I was going to write Strangers, I was like, well, I don't, I can't read any now.
But I do have people send them to me, like to blurb and stuff, you know, like, like the little blurbs in the back of a book.
Yeah. So like publishers will say, hey, we do. And so I end up reading them that way. So I get people who send those and I read them. I read them now.
Like on behalf of your publisher, you mean?
Yeah. Or some other publisher, somebody will say, you know, like, hey, you're the guy who wrote Strangers.
You know, like, will you blurb this? And I always I'm always like, yeah, of course, you know, awesome. Yeah, that's cool.
And just to provide context, if someone hasn't caught on yet, Kevin Hazard is an author and a paramedic. Are you do you still keep your medic or you former paramedic?
How do we refer to former paramedic now about to be about to be a nurse like you made it? Do you keep your numbers? You keep your medic numbers? I do. Yeah.
Since you just like challenge the test every couple of years, I get enough hours through like I get enough CEU hours through work that I can just do it by CE's.
And you never have to work a shift. I mean, I don't have to work that much, but I do have to work shifts. But like my I still fly. So those shifts fill both. Yeah.
OK. Yeah. So we don't really we don't really differentiate like the medic role versus nurse role other than on your paycheck. Yeah.
Everybody on the helicopters, both? No, no, it's just like we don't distinguish. So like we just treat all clinicians the same on the clinical side. It's just the nurses make more money. Gotcha.
Which is a bummer for the medic, man. Yeah. Well, they can go to nursing school like the rest of us. Don't do it. It sucks.
How did you get into writing? I think I remember you talking about this once that you initially started with just a blog.
For the book. Yeah. You know, I had been a reporter before I got into all this stuff. I knew that like someday I would make my way back to that. I just didn't have a timeline.
And then I kind of got like two things happen. One, I'd been around any mess long enough. Like my early stories were just sort of like drifting out of the back of my brain.
And people will be like, hey, tell him that story of this thing. And I would do it. And they would jump in. No, no, no, no. You missed a detail. And I realized like I was forgetting these things.
And then the other was like, and I'm sure you get the same thing. People asking you over and over to tell the same stories. And I kind of got tired. I was like, I'm just going to write something down. And then you just send them to the, you know.
Yeah. I mean, how many times can you sit in a bar and like tell the same funny or not story before you're tired of that story yourself? Now is how it started.
But I just started writing the blog and it was fun to tell these crazy stories. And then I'm, I'm,
Was the blog just about EMS stuff or was it just something you did in general?
It was just EMS stuff. It was, it was, you know, it was like, okay, here's some, here's some crazy stories. And then, or like what the experiences, you know, what does it actually feel like to do all these things?
And then after I've been doing that for a little while, I've written maybe six or something. I get this email from a friend I hadn't talked to in a while. And he was like, hey, dude, been a while. Came across this seems like your sense of humor thought you'd enjoy it.
And it was this email that had been forwarded. And the crazy thing was the email signatures were all over the world. And at the bottom of the email was my blog post.
And I was like, oh, shit, there's an audience for this people, besides just my friends who want to hear the stupid things that I've done. And that list is very, the list of dumb things I've done is long.
But, you know, oh, oh, oh, oh, so people are either going to be entertained by this or whatever. And so that was the, the idea to write the book, but I didn't anticipate was how.
And I always think you sound like a loser when you say the word cathartic. But I mean, it really was, you know, it's a weird decade to, you know, like, come on in your early 20s to your early 30s and be on an ambulance.
Just so it's strange. And you worked, you worked in Atlanta, like in a pretty busy system, too. Yeah, yeah. I mean, it was it was nuts. Yeah, it was it was wild.
So then, you know, coming out of that, it was, I don't like to overdramatize it, but we all know, like, it kind of like messes with your head a little bit, you know, you're you're just sort of, you know, even if you're never too high or too low, you do can tell that like, oh, my feet are sitting differently on the ground than they used to.
There's something off with me or something different about me. And I didn't really know how to what it all was. Writing the book helped me to kind of figure out where that journey had taken me, you know, on a mental level on, you know, personal level, all these other things, you know, so the book was really cool in our garden.
Yeah. Yeah. If anyone has to read it, they should definitely check it out.
I actually got my daughter's reading it right now. And there's an updated chapter. So she's reading an old copy. And I said, when you're done, let me know. I'll give you the updated chapter so you can.
It's an excellent marketing scheme. So now I have to buy another book. You do have to buy another book. Well, so people are asking me, like, you know, I go to these events and people will say, so what's it like now? And I can't answer that question. You know, I can't answer that question.
But I did want to know myself. And so I went back and I did. I did a ride along with Grady. That's awesome. Yeah, I did an overnight shift, which is insane. And what was really crazy was a medic that I was with was there because he had read strangers and moved to Atlanta to work at Grady specific. Yeah, it was nuts.
And did you randomly get assigned to him or was that like planned by someone on the back end? Yeah, somebody was like, this is the guy you need to ride because everybody knew why he was at Grady. That's a few people there like that. But but yeah, it was it was I mean, in, of course, crazy night, like, you know, it was going to go one of two ways. We were going to do nothing. Or like the doors are going to fall off. And we just had a little bit of a
conversation. And we just, you know, it was like, two traumatic arrests, stabbing cardiac arrest, like it was like, nonstop, nonstop all night. It was fun. It was really a good time. Yeah. And how long had it been since you were since you were there since you hung up your hat? I left in 2013. I did that ride along in 2024. So it's been 11 years. And yeah, that's a long time. Yeah. And all of COVID, you know, that was really the crazy thing was being able and that was kind of what I wanted to know, was how had COVID affected it.
And, you know, the sort of not surprising, but, you know, heartbreaking part of it was all the people I knew pretty much were gone. There was like two left, you know, that had like, wiped the debts clean. So you think of all that history that's been lost, you know, the connection to the past that that was part of what made that place so special. Yeah, you know, it's been severed.
Yeah, I imagine it's like in a lot of places now. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. I'm similarly, I haven't been on a, I haven't like worked a shift on a 911 truck in, yeah, since like 2013, I think it's been about the same amount of time. Like I still like have some exposure to it through like the flight stuff, but it's different. It's not the same. It's not the same as like being on a truck all night long and just like running around town.
Yeah, at one point, at one point, we parked on some side street, like 2am, you know, under like a street light, you know, this orange light coming down, you can hear like people yelling somewhere in the distance, windows roll down our feet, like up on a dash.
And it was just kind of one of those moments where it's like, it was like time compressed, you know, and it was 2007 again. And I was 24. And just kind of like, it was the weirdest, weirdest feeling. I mean, in a lot of ways, so many things come right back to you the minute you have that opportunity.
But that was like, that was just the most real thing to be sitting there and be like, holy shit, like, I probably been in this very ambulance. I know I've been on this very street.
Yeah.
Do you miss it?
No, I mean, look, do you miss like sitting in an ambulance in the rain, you know, staring at the windshield park behind some grocery store with like rats running in out of the dumpster? I don't miss spending seven hours doing that for sure.
Or like running up and down stairs to get like enormous people who've gone to the third floor for no good reason. You know, like fighting with nurses because we shouldn't have brought another patient to their hospital, which is on diversion or all those fun things.
But like, you know, like, tell me you don't miss this. Tell me that if somebody said to you, hey, this Friday night is going to be 72 clear sky, your favorite partner and you are going to give you the night shift and you guys go and just go crazy in the city.
Like, I would do that in Harvey. That's the part I miss. But that's like 3% of the job, you know.
Yeah, totally. Yeah, I think about that sometimes that it would be cool to go back to working on a truck in a city again someday. I also think it'd be different now that like, I'm a little more grown up and like, not as dependent on like a terribly paying job to like make ends meet.
Like, I think it'd be fun to go back and do it now when there's no financial stress involved, which is like, you know, kind of like one of the reasons why I left and I think a lot of people leave is because you don't like make that good of money.
Yeah, no, it's cul-de-sac, unfortunately. Yeah, totally.
Yeah. I don't know, man. I don't know. Like I said, there are aspects of it. Although I missed something enough to go to nursing school, you know, and I wasn't sure what it was.
In 2018, I was researching what eventually became Sirens. But at that time, it was just a magazine article. I was at, I mean, so like, I am, I've been paid by a big magazine to travel across the country.
I am at the archives at Harvard University, researching this famous doctor for this incredible story. I have a phone call later that afternoon about an adaptation I'm doing of one of my books for this TV show.
In theory, that should have been like, everything should have been perfect. And I'm reading about this doctor working for AMRIF, you know, the Flying Doctors in Africa and her doing all this relief work.
And I just felt this huge pang of, like, it hit me suddenly, like, oh my God, you let your numbers expire. You're no longer like you aren't this anymore. And you can't get it back. And it's gone.
And look at all these things that you're not a part of. And I like, in the moment that it should have been as content as possible.
There was this, like, panicky feeling of like, oh my God, I there's a part of me that I've lost. And I thought, well, that's it. I can't get that back. And then this weird phone call comes in the middle of the pandemic.
I find myself in Central Florida of all frickin places and some weird like tool that's infested with bees sleeping in a hammock like nine other weirdos. And one night, one of those weirdos.
Was like, hey, dude, have you ever thought about an ABSN? Because I think I relayed that story to you. And you were like, why don't you just go get an ABSN? Like, just go do that.
And that was June of 2020, that conversation of you and I sitting around, why we had a bonfire and was 94 degrees in Central Florida. I don't know, but that thing's raging.
We were camping.
Yeah. And that moment when you said that, I was like, oh, and that sort of, you know, sent me down this other weird trajectory that I had not anticipated.
Yeah, that's awesome. And you're almost done, right?
Yep. Yep. Finishing up right now. I mean, I have two finals for my last two classes are next week.
Awesome. And where are you gonna, I already know the answer to this, since we were talking about it beforehand, but where are you gonna end up working?
So, you know, they're really in Atlanta, there are two hospitals I always wanted to work for. One was Grady. And I assumed that when I did this, that's where I was going to go. I mean, I love Grady. It's one of those weird places that it's like, really difficult.
But you take pride in that difficulty, you know, and it kind of like the, the, the, the place just sort of sinks into your bones if you're one of those people. So I thought this was going to go. The other hospital I have over there, I think, is the hospital that I've been working with.
I've always really liked this Children's Show, Children's Healthcare of Atlanta. It's just like, it's a good health system. They do great work. My son was there in the ICU.
And everybody I've ever known who's gone there has been really, really happy. And so when I did my Peds rotation, I was at the brand new hospital that they had, which is like robots driving around and all this.
The things that they have, it's been like, dude, there's this outside play area. It's like with a bit of like walking trails and big fountains and all this, like, it's crazy.
But when I did my Peds rotation, I was like, well, wait a minute, I think, you know, because, you know, on an ambulance, you treat a ton of kids, you know, like, febrile seizures and like, tons and tons and tons of RSV, bronchiolitis and asthma and all that stuff.
So I was comfortable enough with kids. And then I did that. And I was like, Oh, I think I kind of like this. So I sort of applied just like, hey, let's see what happens. And I got an interview with their cardiac acute care unit.
They brought me up and, you know, they were like, you know, I had a friend who was at the, who was at great ECV ICU. And so I know that those are, you know, it's like cool stuff to be done. And I was talking to the nurse. I was like, so what do you guys do?
And she's like, you know, tons of ads, tons of people who are, you know, either waiting or just coming off transplants, a lot of like, major cardiac defects. And, you know, like, basically like, super sick kids, like, it's an intense unit.
And not for everybody. But if you can handle it, it's like a great place. And every literally every word she was saying was like, yes, yes, yes. I mean, you're either, either one of those people who who hears that somebody's gonna be really difficult. And you're like, hell, yeah. Or you're not.
Like, I mean, you're sitting here doing rotations in Gaza, like, you know, you know, like you go out of your way for those kinds of experiences. And the more she described it tomorrow, I was like, uh, huh, I think this is I'm gonna be and then so yeah.
And it's all lined up. You got the job. Yeah, man. Awesome. Yeah, it's all your fault. It should be like, I'll take I'll take responsibility for that. I'm okay with it.
Yeah, I'm gonna back up. I had a question I wanted to ask you about when you were working on writing strangers. I don't remember where I heard you tell the story was on another podcast.
And you were talking about how once you had it drafted, like how you went about finding a publisher, I think story was like went to a bookstore and just like looked at books in the same genre as yours and just like wrote down the publishers and like, since your, since your manuscript to them.
Sort of. So, in order to get a major publisher, you need to have an agent, like the agent is that's kind of like the gatekeeper. So your agent is the one who approaches the publisher. Okay, I see. So, somebody had said to me one time, everybody, it wasn't Oh, Stephen King.
If he didn't say I wish so, Steve and I were talking this one time we're up in Maine, you know, we're even lobster rolls and but but in that book on writing. He made a comment that everybody, you know, he always when he gets a book, he always flips the acknowledgement pages and looks to see who they
thanked. And, you know, when somebody thinks a spouse, you know, he's like, that's somebody who gets it. They understand the help that you get. But he made a mention the fact like everybody thinks her agent everything's her publisher.
And I was like, Oh, like, here's a great way to connect. So I went to every bookstore that was in driving distance at my house. And I walked into the memoir section, and every book that wasn't like a celebrity memoir.
I flipped to the back.
And sure enough, dude, like almost all of them thank their agent.
I write down the name of the book, the name of the writer and the agent.
And I did that I just spent hours just going through every single memoir and then I go to another book, I did the same thing. And I collected this list, and I put together a letter that basically said,
I just read, you know, back from Gaza by Ryan Kerr. And since my book is like that one, I thought you might want to represent this as well. And then I gave like a brief two sentence description of what my book was and then the first chapter.
And I sent out 20 of those a day, every single day for a couple weeks.
And then I started getting responses.
And then I got my agent through that process but that was that came after like, you know, all sorts of try and fail things to figure out how to like break through and then ultimately it was just like volume, you know, just like, huh, right.
Yeah, I've done something like similar in my life but not like more for like applying for jobs like for years, I would just like every couple months sit down and like, I'd always keep a list of like cool opportunities.
And I would just, yeah, I would just like send my resume and follow up on emails and like, it was like an ongoing process for a long time and that's kind of how I was able to get like my foot in the door doing a lot of the international work I do now.
This just like takes a lot of persistence to, to like break in to like get get noticed, I guess.
Yeah, I mean I think that's, that's, there's that really long quote about persistence.
And I've got like a big poster of it and I hung it up outside my kids room.
You don't have it memorized.
I've got a memorize but it's too long but but the idea is like, you know, like genius doesn't get you there's like tons of unrewarded genius and all these other you know, there are plenty of like talent doesn't do it there's the world's full of talented derelicts.
The only thing that, you know, is going to solve the human problem is persistence.
And, I mean, I just believe that like, like, you were trying to do something that a lot of people in theory would like to do.
And a lot of qualified people already do. And so, like, you were trying to reach people who are busy, you know, and like by by nature of what you were trying to do like they were probably in other places.
And they're like, I don't have any given moments of like getting through is gonna be difficult.
But you got to just like keep banging on the door and people reach out to me all the time and they'll say like oh I'm frustrated and I'm like yes, you should be frustrated like be frustrated, like let it piss you off.
I mean I used to just walk into bookstores, this sounds so stupid, but I used to walk into bookstores, and I would just look at like there's 10,000 you go to Barnes and Noble there's like 100,000 books in it right.
And I was like, are you trying to tell me that all 100,000 of these motherfuckers are just better than me. Like, that's what you're trying to tell me, like, no way.
Maybe maybe like 90,000 of them but not all. At least 10,000 here that I can that can outrun. And, and that was, you know, like that was my philosophy was like, I can't be worse than everybody.
So I just, I just haven't gotten the opportunity so let me just keep like, keep shooting, you know, like if you're not a sniper be a volume shooter I guess.
Yeah, yeah, totally that makes sense.
Yeah.
Another question I've been thinking about is when, how did you come across the siren story.
Because we talked about this, like in the past, because like I went to school, I did paramedic school in Pittsburgh and like never knew about, I never knew the story, like I didn't know that was a thing, which is kind of crazy to me in hindsight.
I was curious like how, yeah, like how you got a lead on that story.
I got an email, August of 2018 from somebody who said, okay, read strangers. Have you ever heard of this other story.
And it, you know, reference Freedom House and I was like I don't know what that is.
Well, and I see and at that time, they were like, I don't know, man they were they were a handful of, you know, I think, University of Pittsburgh's magazine had done something short on it you know like a 500 board piece.
And there were little bits and pieces of things here and there.
And I kept thinking as I was researching it once I got an idea of what it was that it was like these, you know, this paramedic programs preceded Los Angeles and Miami and Seattle.
And that they were all black eyes, and that there had been, you know, I couldn't tell exactly what but there was clearly some issues with the city.
I know there's a story here. So let me and so I just kept, you know, and all those little stories that popped up.
There'd be a name, you know, like john moon or Mitch Brown or George McCary and so I just started writing down, Walt Brown I just started writing that every name I came across.
And then I was trying to find these people.
And luckily, you know, they, they were a bunch of more around. They were able to answer the phone but that's how it started was realizing that there was this thing and I didn't know exactly what it was at first I just had, you know, it's like one of those things like you're feeling in the dark and you touch something and you're like,
all right, there's some heft to whatever it is here in front of me and that was kind of what it was. I was like, all right.
So I don't know what this is yet but I know it's good. And then I started talking to people, and their stories were fascinating and I was like, Oh, this is like this is real like there's a real thing here.
So I just kept at it and kept at it and kept at it and, you know, the story just sort of like unfolded, little by little but that was how it started.
Is that something you're like always on the look for like are you always like keeping your ear to the ground like looking for stories or that one kind of just like fall into your lap like how does because I know you have a background in journalism.
So I was curious if that's just something that you've cultivated with time like looking for that kind of stuff or if it's just.
Yeah, I mean, there's.
I kind of do it one of two ways, either.
I just sort of listen to people like I get in people like oh you should write a story about this you should write a story about that.
You have to have some sense of like what is or is not a story or what just feels like ground you've already walked on.
But sometimes somebody will say something to you and you're like, Oh, other times like that one somebody mentioned something and I just started digging and kind of immediately realize that like, Oh, nobody has really dug into this like I'm here by myself.
Let me let me attack it.
Sometimes somebody will say like the book that I have coming out next month.
I knew some of the people involved in that story. So I knew it was always in the back of my head. I was like, Okay, I know these guys did this crazy thing.
And I'll bet if I really dug into it that it did there's a cool story in there. So I just kind of let it simmer until I was ready and then I sort of approached them and was like, Hey, would you be willing, you know, and I sort of did my best to say, you know, to give them like the 10 second like,
This is all the cool shit that I'll be able to do if you open the doors.
And as luck would have it, they had the same idea. They were like, Hey, you know, maybe I wonder if you willing to write this story. So as soon as they started pitching it, they were like, Hell, yes, like, you know, so it was good.
And there's there's another story that I'm having a hard time. It is an insane story. But it's, it's a difficult for whatever reason, it's a difficult sell.
But the reason I the way I found that was I was like, What am I, what's a place in a time that I'm interested in.
I found a place in a time. And I went to like, I just started pulling up, like just going through newspapers from that era. And I was like, there's just bound to be a pattern here.
There's like something that happened at this place in this time, I guarantee it. And sure enough, like you'll find things there's that you know, what's that story? There's some dude who had he made enough.
The way I sort of remember is like he made a bet with his friends. And he was like, I bet you that any day, any month and a year, if you just drew it out of a hat, something fascinating, truly, truly fascinating happened on that day.
And so he had a one friend pick a day and one friend pick a month, one friend pick a year. And that was his book. So he wrote, and it was like sometime in the 80s. So let's just say it's like, March 17 1983 is the thing.
And then he writes this book, and it turns out like crazy, crazy earth shattering things happen there. And, you know, so you could go to literally any place in any time.
And you're gonna find cool stuff also like people, you know, I mean, like you're there are people right now in New Mexico, like if they took the time to turn around and have a conversation with you, they'd walk away and be like, dude, I was just talking to this skinny nurse over here and you wouldn't believe like what he told me, you know,
it like people are fascinating. So like, yeah, I do it all kinds of ways.
That's cool. And then the new book that's coming out, it's coming out, like in a couple weeks, right? Yeah, March 3. What's it all about?
So ending though, we want people to read it.
I'll give you the opening.
So July of 2014.
July of 2014. This guy by the name of Dent Thompson, Dent Thompson is on vacation, sitting on his back deck, he's got a beer in a magazine, he's chilling out.
And he's got this mountain house.
Look from his where he sits on his deck, he's got this like 100 mile view of the Tennessee divide, sort of like, nice afternoon.
It's about three o'clock. He's just starting to relax and cell phone rings.
And he looks down and DC area code. So he answers.
And the guy on the other end of the line is from the State Department's Division of Operational Medicine.
And he says, some Americans, we don't yet know how many,
are dying of Ebola in West Africa. We're not exactly sure where.
We have tried everywhere else.
There's not a government, a military or an organization that can or will get them out.
You are their last chance for survival.
I'll give you five minutes to decide if you're willing to transport them.
Click.
And so the book is Who the fuck is Dent Thompson?
Why is he gets this? Why does he get this phone call?
And what are the seven days that follow that phone call?
Think like the perfect storm meets the hot zone.
I've seen one of those. So I got like half an idea.
Which one have you seen? Wait, the hot zone is a book, man.
I've seen the perfect storm. There was a movie for the perfect storm, right?
Did you not read the book?
You're killing me.
No, I've read a couple of his other books, though.
But yeah, I haven't read that one because I saw the movie.
So I was like, I don't want to like repeat it.
Just have a thing to say to an author.
There's a lot you're missing out on. But the hot zone, you've never read the hot zone.
I don't even know if I've heard of it.
Oh, really? That's the book that kind of like started all this stuff.
So this dude, Richard Preston.
And this was sort of the this is kind of the first time people hear about Ebola.
It's Ebola was discovered in 1976.
So he writes this book about Ebola and
laughing at it.
And it's like a crazy like everybody's mind is blown about like this horrible virus because, you know, it's like nobody knows hemorrhagic fever, you know.
But we know that like, oh, this is like really scary virus that kills people in crazy ways.
So the hot zone is about in the kind of like about Ebola.
And there's all these different things.
This is crazy sequence where a bunch of monkeys get it in Virginia and bananas.
Do you need to read it? It's good. It's really good.
But but yeah, that's what the book is about. No one's coming.
Comes out March 3rd. You can preorder now.
Nice. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm going to have to wait six weeks till I can read it.
Yeah. Now that's on you.
You got to get your schedule locked down.
How long are you going to be gone for?
I my rotation over there is five weeks.
So I'm due back to the states like middle of April.
But I may stay I may stay over in Jordan and do some vacationing before I come back.
We'll see.
Yeah. And what do you like?
What's your specific role?
So most of what we're trying to do is facilitate medical evacuations,
getting people out of Gaza.
So yeah, up until just recently,
it's been a little bit difficult because the border crossing with Egypt wasn't open.
But it just opened the day after I the day or two after I left this last time.
So now the team back there is doing like almost daily medivacs,
getting people out.
And then when we have downtime,
we also help out working in an emergency room at a field hospital for the Palestinian Red Crescent.
OK. What's the what's the patient population?
I mean, right now the the patients that were medivaccing,
most of them are kids and a lot of them have like congenital conditions or are cancer patients.
So they need like, yeah, they need like prolonged care that's not available in Gaza at the moment.
And then in the in the hospital where we're working, it's mostly medical cases nowadays.
A lot of like exacerbations of chronic conditions just because people haven't had access to primary health care for quite a while.
There's like a lot of medications are just in short supply.
So yeah.
Crazy. Yeah.
Nice man. Yeah.
But we didn't come on this call to talk about me. We're going to talk about you.
What is next? You mentioned this one story that you're trying to pin down.
Do you have any other future plans for other books you want to write or other things you want to look into?
Yeah.
There's there's always like a handful of things.
There's I know this guy who's a transplant surgeon and I look I love the idea of both telling both ends of that story.
You know, I mean, I could so I think about that for a moment, you know, it's like on the one end of the spectrum.
Such a tragedy.
But on the other end of the spectrum, it's like literally a miracle.
I mean, it's like days that X Mackinac like literally.
I mean, it's like from the sky, this life saving things just drops into your lap or your chest.
And like so I just find that endlessly fascinating.
So that like that's sort of always kicking around somewhere in my head.
I like I think I like a lot of people I do like a kind of like a crime stories.
The thing that I found that I've been having a difficult time for all sorts of complicated reasons selling.
It sits at the intersection of medicine and crime.
And I just thought like bang perfect.
And then there's this other complicating factor.
But basically the short version is a few other books that are sort of in the universe but different did not do very well.
And so you've either got to wait for people to forget about those or find someone who is convinced that your angle is different enough.
But that's just a sick one those bombers, you know, where they're like, yeah, the last three books we tried and you know, and I'm like, no, no, no, this was totally different.
But it doesn't matter.
But I would love to find something like that.
You know, but but but like in, you know, in your world, you know, I think we're so joined into Central Florida into Mexico, the Middle East, like, there's like a lot of really cool stuff that happens there.
And I would love to look into that like, you know, there's got to be someone other than other than Navy SEALs who are telling stories about things that happen overseas, you're like, aren't there enough books about like, you know, so that I came in and I shot 17 people, you know, I entered the room and I stabbed everybody I saw.
You know, there's like other versions of, you know, Americans going overseas and doing crazy shit that other than those guys.
So, you know, yeah, where's the, you know, where's the Ryan Kerr story, you know what I mean?
That's what I'd like to know.
Yeah.
What's that?
Maybe Sunday.
Yeah, you should, you should, you should.
But I would love to do something like that.
Find another I do, weirdly enough, I don't know why I really love writing about like crazy stuff that exists in the world of medicine, you know, I mean, like this book that's coming out right now.
I mean, it's Ebola. It's, you know, this crazy international rescue planes are involved pilots, engineers, the government's sort of involved like Barack Obama is a character in this book.
You know, there's elements of the government they're trying to stop it from happening. So it's like all kinds of crazy stuff that makes it really fun.
But, you know, in various parts of it, the medicine touches down and I just, I don't know why I like it so much but you know that there's something about that to just, there's an excitement by the way that some people like are super into writing about war.
I, the sort of human and extremist that I like to look at is, is the medicine side, you know,
you're just right when you have like a lead on publishing a book or you, you just write in general.
Well right now, I always have some project that's underway, used to be I would just write any, any old time.
I don't quite have that luxury anymore. I have the other luxury, which is that people are paying me to do it which is like, that is not, you know, that's not nothing.
So there's like some TV stuff, I'm in the middle of a movie project right now.
And there's some TV stuff and then obviously there's the new book. So, I am busy with these various projects.
What it doesn't necessarily allow is for me to just go off like I have this fun idea that I would love to do for a novel, you know, just like crazy fun story.
But it would require the time to just go off and do something on my own. And I just don't have that right now.
So like author vacations where you just like rent a house in the Caribbean for three months and just get shitfaced every day and write books.
My name is not Dan Brown. Unfortunately, you may have sent your email to the wrong person that I would love, I would love to to be doing that.
Maybe I'll just like, you know, like move into Sam's guest house since I can have a guest house pretty soon.
I'll move in with his guest house to and I'll just like allow his weirdness to inspire me.
Because I'm sure there's some crazy stuff going on.
But no, I would do that.
A few things would make me happier than that, for sure. I mean, who doesn't want to get drunk in a Caribbean, you know.
Yeah, that's fair.
Yeah, maybe not during a hurricane, but like in general.
In general. Yeah. I don't know. Hurricane would be kind of cool.
I've had a friend who used to say like, I want to tie myself to a lawn chair and sit out a hurricane on the beach.
I was like, dude, you can do that. Like that is an attainable goal.
But I think I would check it out. I mean, I'm almost certain I would check it out.
Well, what would be wild about it is that you could watch the bands come in, you know, like it would keep getting closer.
I mean, think about like the the buildup to that, the waiting, you know, I mean, be very jaws like this.
Just be like, do you do you do you get closer and the anticipation of that would be that might like literally be Chinese water torture.
I mean, that might break you. Yeah. It'd be awesome.
If you did it, I feel like you could do that. I think on it, but I probably won't.
Do your kids know you're famous?
So famous, I don't know the word famous, but.
I mean, you're more famous than most people. Okay.
It's a low bar, though. Most of us are really not famous. You know what I mean?
You're like at least in like the top 30 percent of the world, I think.
Okay. I mean, sure, I'll take that. Making numbers up. But yeah, that's the above average, we'll say I'm famous enough that you and I have sat in a car while like three goofy firefighters looked up bad reviews for my book and read them out loud.
So I'll give you that. I'm at least that famous. I actually I think believe that experience happened to us on two different continents.
But so my seventh grader, I have two kids, one's a ninth, one's and seventh. My seventh grader came home and there was a they had to do this thing of like your online footprint.
So because like the schools are trying to kind of teach kids like hey, you got to really be careful.
And so they said, put your parents name in and my name like all this, you know, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, you know, head shots or whatever that from the back of the book and but like stuff from interviews and all the like it just like everybody else's father, you know, was like a LinkedIn page.
You know what I mean? Like, like a normal, you know, so some other kid was like, my dad's a cardiothoracic surgeon, you know, like way more successful than me, but he only appears on LinkedIn.
Or like maybe, you know, Brown University wrote something nice about him, you know, as a 1987 alum or something.
But then of course, it was like all this stuff popped up, which he thought was really cool. They, they're aware of the books they've heard, like my wife has played a couple podcasts that I've been on for them.
And they've been to book signings and stuff, which I think they find sort of like entertaining novel.
And like just really bizarre.
Yeah, but be they're aware that there's this thing that I do, and that it gets attention, which is which is which is cool. You know, I'm glad that they have this kind of weird experience but yes it is strange when they say things like that.
Yeah, yeah, I can imagine that would be like an interesting dynamic as parents.
Yeah, I mean, you know, like my,
I got, I went spoke at Georgia Tech.
And somebody like me my wife was like, No, why Georgia Tech and I was like, Oh, well, like somebody read the book and it inspired them to do this thing and then they told somebody else, and my daughter was like, well I'm going to write a book that inspires somebody to do that.
You know, so like that's cool, but there's a voice inside my head that's like, dude, you know, can hearted his like to get started on this and like, like, are you sure that's really what you want to do like you don't just be a dentist and work four days a week and like have an awesome beach house.
Okay, if you really show this is the life you want, you can't you can't say that to a kid. So I was like, Yeah, no, you totally can. You just got to put in the work. But of course, in my mind, I'm like, can we be a dermatologist like easiest job on earth and make all the money, you know, which I whatever I mean, that's not what I would have done.
So it's not real advice, but I don't know. It's weird. It's a weird thing as a parent because all the things that you do.
Like you would never, you would not encourage your kids to do the stuff that you do. Like things that you don't. Yeah, the things that you don't believe are risks.
I guarantee your parents are like, Brian's going to Gaza, like, Oh my god, he's going to Gaza.
I mean, my kids get on bird scooters and I'm like, what if they fall, like they're gonna, you know, and like things like, why would I, why would you even think that you wouldn't, but it's just, it's weird with your kids like you, you really freak out.
I don't recommend it. Don't do it.
Stay not kid.
How much, how much time do you have to put in to like doing non writing things for the books, like doing interviews and going to book signings and like doing like the tour thing.
Do you have to do much of that or is that something that you're allowed to do like when it suits you?
No, I kind of, I mean, you know, if you're competing with TikTok, like you got to hustle.
You know what I mean? And let's be honest, like, everybody, I mean, there's a reason that.
Wisdom from Kevin Hazard. Yeah, man.
You know, they make a movie right now that's got like every famous person in the planet on it. Nobody goes to see it like walk into a movie theater with a Brad Pitt movie right now you're gonna be the only person there.
Everybody's at home looking at their phones like it's a we live in a very weird time.
So you got to really hustle to get people's attention.
And I've been lucky really like insanely lucky that that strangers and sirens for different reasons struck a chord with people.
And I have been asked to go on podcasts and I've.
I don't know. I think I've been to all over the country, particularly with sirens.
The medical community, like, embrace that in a way that I did not anticipate. So that part is cool, though.
The podcasting is way better, in a sense, because it doesn't require me to fly across the country to go somewhere.
However, each of those things, you know, you sell however many books. And if it's a big audience, you sell a lot of books and that's, you know, like a really cool thing.
And a huge audience.
You're a giant audience. Yeah. But, you know, I don't know.
There's but there's like legwork, you know, man. Yeah, like you and I know each other. So you can just what's happening.
Like, hey, do you want to come on? Yeah, that's that's been too long since we talked. Let's do it.
But most of it is like me trying to keep lists or databases or whatever of podcasts or festivals or conferences that have had me in the past and reaching back out to them, which takes a while or doing social media stuff, which I think there's some people.
Like it is so easy for them. I cannot tell you how hard it is for me. And it goes against every thing.
But like, because you go, you're like walking out in front of people you don't really know. Be like, hey, look at me. Look at this cool thing I did.
And you're either cool with that or you find it mortifying. And I find it mortifying. It's just like I'm always familiar. Like every time I hit send on a post, I'm like, geez, you know, I like I'm sure these people are like this guy again.
I'm so self conscious about it. So it really like I'll put off like I'll be like, all right, I should post something about the book. I'll put it off for days because I just don't want to get all this anxiety about it because I just I would be such a bad salesman.
You know what I started doing is I do my social media stuff now on like an app that schedules it.
So like, because I had the same thing when I like go to post something, I'm like, like, is this is it ready? Is it good? Like, but now I like just schedule it and then like I don't even know what day it goes out because it's like three weeks later.
And then it's like happens in the ether and then someone sends me a message and I'm like, oh, yeah, cool. Like someone got it and they liked it. And I like has kind of helped me navigate that part of things.
Oh, that's interesting.
I would love to be one of those people who just is like a social media manager. Like, that's a kind of money. Like, forget money to go to the islands for three months. Like, I want social media manager money like to not have to think about it.
Just have somebody else do it would be awesome.
If I wouldn't do it, if not, if I wasn't trying to, you know, be engaged with a community that, you know, luckily has enjoyed and responded to the work that I've done.
You know, that's why like, that's that's the reason that I do it, you know, like people have read my books and they've been nice enough to reach out and be like, hey, man, this meant this to me.
So like I owe those people, you know, to continue to do stuff. But then also you're trying to serve like the next book. So it's yeah, I would love. I would love not to have to do it.
But that's a long way of saying like, a lot of time, there's a lot of non writing time out there.
I mean, and you're like you do others like I'm sure you probably have like, you know, it's kind of basically comes down to clerical. Like, I'm sure you have all kinds of weird things because you like you do travel nursing and you've got your home thing and you've got your overseas work.
Like, there's got to be a lot of stuff that you have to mess around with.
Yeah, I could use a personal assistant if anyone's interested.
Yes, yes, yes, we need Tucker, man. Like, let's hire that dude.
Yeah, you know, I am working for a GRM person now. I don't know if you ever met Mark McDonald.
I think we communicated.
Yeah, he like took over my spot on the Madame Morris project after I left, but he now is the executive director for a small nonprofit free clinic here in Santa Fe.
And I work for him part time as an MP now. And they're trying to get Tucker to come out to New Mexico and work there. So it may come full circle.
You'll have to come do a book signing at the clinic.
Did I be all about that? I'd be all about that. I'd be about that anyway. I haven't I've only driven through New Mexico. I have not had the privilege. So.
Yeah, you should come out. It's beautiful.
That's what I hear. Yeah, I might get stuck, though. That's what they say. Our state motto is the land of enchantment, but everyone calls it the land of entrapment.
What is that?
Yeah, because you get stuck and never leave.
Do you like it?
No, I just got stuck here.
I hate it.
I'm just kidding. I like it a lot. It's cool. It's a great spot for like outdoor stuff because it's like really cool mountains and not a lot of people, which is perfect. It's the best combo.
Yeah, that's why I kind of like the Nevada side of Lake Tahoe.
Yeah, because there's just not a lot of people out there. It doesn't have that same craziness. I was in Reno a couple of years ago.
It's a weird place, but the edge of town when you get away from all the casinos, there's this river that runs through and they've got crazy access.
There are steps everywhere. You can walk just straight into the river, run through the city. They rent duckies. You can just like hop on one and tube the city restaurants.
And of course, the mountains are right there. Now it's Reno. So it's like got that going on. But there's like, you know, I know you're the same way.
Like I love the desert. They can either speak to you or it doesn't like that. Auster it is either something you love or you're like, I don't want to be part of it.
When I'm in those kind of environments, I just I just feel myself open up in a way that I'm not in a lot of other places.
So yeah, I feel like New Mexico. My wife's like, not sure. But I've been pushing for New Mexico.
Yeah, we can only spring her out here to visit.
I know. Not to move, but you can come check it out. Yeah. Need to need to. Where are you? What like?
I have a place in Albuquerque, but this month in between rotations, I'm staying up in Santa Fe. Yeah.
That's cool. Is it cool? I feel like I've heard crazy things about it.
Maybe heard.
I don't know that it's like a lot of like 56 year old divorcee is trying to hand up pottery.
I mean, I think there's an element of that. Yeah, like in northern New Mexico. Yeah.
That's a small part.
Yeah, but there's other stuff too. So it's fine. All right. Well, you know, there's a
lot of things that's just not wrong with that.
Clutter is important. Yeah. Well, that's all the questions I had about the books. I don't know. Anything else you want to share with the folks listening?
Oh, I can't put me in a spot like that. Too late. Yeah. I don't know. I'm just enjoying sharing things about you. Yeah.
Well, everyone go by. Go buy all three of Kevin's books. Yeah. Yeah, man. A thousand naked strangers, American sirens, and very, very soon no one's coming.
Which is a really cool book. I'm very excited about it. It's a such a fun story. Like I wrote it so quickly. It just like one of those things. I spent, you know, a year or something doing all these interviews and it was just like, because it was just once you had it all you can just lay it all out.
Yeah. It was just such a, I don't know the story like really flowed quickly. I was like, Dan, this is because it like the pace of it. You know, when you when something happens over the course of seven days, like you think it didn't, you know, it's like three days in the Condor, you know, like you're being you're being chased. And so just the writing was really quick. It's awesome.
Yeah, I'm stoked to check it out. I have to I have to order it. So it's you when I come back. Yeah.
Do you have time to read out there?
I do. Yeah, I take my Kindle. So yeah, I have like a decent amount of downtime kind of depends on the day, like some days when I'm working in the emergency room, it's slow and I can read there. Sometimes we get stuck in like holding points when we're doing medivacs where you just stuck for like two or three hours. Well, yeah, people are busy fighting each other.
Right.
So yeah, it kind of it's a little bit variable. But yeah, I'm doing a promotional copy. If you have time to read it, you can bring it with you.
Will it will make you here in time?
When you leave the second.
Yeah, no, I have promotional copies.
Sweet. Cool. Perfect. Yeah, man. Give me your address right now. Tell the whole world what your address is.
Yes, send me a thing and I'll put one in the mail and you can bring it with you. Perfect. Yeah. Take like some badass picture with it in the background. Okay, I can do that.
I'll stop the recording here because I don't know if everyone wants to listen to us just banter. Yeah, they do. I mean, they probably do.
I don't know if it stopped. It should tell us. It should say we've stopped recording. If I can figure out how to do this.